- Jackson, do you like bento lunches?
- What's a bento lunch?
- You're about to find out.
(upbeat jingle)
Pinterest moms.
What are they and why am I
talking about them today?
Well let me tell you,
a Pinterest mom is a rare breed of mother
who is just like, the most extra.
So she's that mom who makes
the homemade birthday party
favors at every party.
She's that mom who home cooks every meal.
She's the mom who's cleaning products
in her home are all made from scratch.
This is like the complete
opposite of everything I'm used to
and the way I am as a parent
but I wanna give it a shot.
I wanna try something new.
So for one week, I'm going
to be a Pinterest mom.
I'm not going to be able to quit my job
or like stop all my
other responsibilities,
but in all my free time, I'm going to act
as if I was a Pinterest mom,
and see how it goes.
Okay, so I am trolling
Pinterest and today is Sunday
so I'm gonna take full advantage of that
and the fact that I don't go to work,
and do three activities.
I'm gonna find a food, a DIY
for my kids to play with,
and a DIY to better my household.
Jackson!
Hi.
- Hugging.
- Thank you.
This lunch took me about
half an hour to make.
Uh, I tried to do the
puzzle piece sandwich
which doesn't really work.
So having kids of 2 different ages,
uh, five and two,
a lot of these Pinterest things
that I spent a lot of time on
were completely lost on Wyatt.
He's like two years old, he doesn't care.
Spent 30 minutes on this
lunch and this is what's left.
(sigh)
But Jackson was another story.
- They're puzzle pieces!
- Oh, you saw they're puzzle pieces?
- Yeah.
- Oh my gosh. Worth it.
But yeah, it was nice to
see that he was interacting
with a lot of the stuff that I was making.
It was sweet.
So now I'm going to make
these popsicles I saw
that look super easy on Pinterest.
It says you just mix
Sprite and gummi bears
in a popsicle mold and it
makes these really cute, clear
popsicles with gummi bears in them.
Okay, I'm on my third task
and it is DIY garbage disposal pods.
Because apparently you need these
to keep your garbage
disposals smelling fresh.
These seem fairly easy.
I actually found them
from NIFTY on Facebook.
Uh, and so if NIFTY
can do it, I can do it.
I don't understand how people
find the hours of the day
to do all of this.
So this is my, uh garbage
disposal pod mixture.
It's like, kinda sticky.
And then I'm just gonna pack it
into this silicone ice cube mold,
and I guess it takes 24
hours for these to like, dry.
So I can't use 'em till tomorrow.
The final Pinterest craft for today
is making your own fun shaped crayons.
- Yay!
- I don't understand this one.
But basically, you buy a pack of crayons,
like regular crayons,
and then break them up
and combine the colors,
and put them in a silicone baking mold.
- And don't forget to take paper off.
- Don't, do not forget
to take the paper off.
Speaking of my kids,
any time I did one of these projects,
I turn around and there'd be a giant,
freakin' mess behind me,
because my back was turned for so long,
and I was distracted for so long,
my kids would take every
opportunity to like,
do whatever they wanted.
Okay, these are done.
Uh, they look very questionable.
I do not understand these.
Like, just give your
kid a pack of crayons.
We spent six dollars on a silicone mold
and 45 minutes making these.
Okay, we're on day three and I tried
using one of these uh,
garbage disposal pods
and they are completely
crumbling and they don't work.
So I did something wrong
and also uh, I need to go to work,
so I'm failing at making
their bento lunches.
Because it's either make
that or get dressed for work,
and I need to show up for work in clothes,
I think that's important so,
(laughs)
fail today.
So why didn't I just get
up a little bit earlier
to get all of this stuff done?
Well, I already get up
very early to go to work
and I work pretty far
away from where I live,
so my commute is three hours, total.
Uh, but it wasn't all bad.
I'll say this,
you know, if I didn't work full-time,
I can totally understand how
that could be really exciting to do
and really fun to do.
And you can take the time
to incorporate your kids
into a lot of these crafts
and a lot of these projects.
So I totally forgot about
these popsicles I made
with the gummi bears and Sprite,
and first, they uh,
completely exploded all over the freezer.
I don't know if you can tell,
but they're dripped all over.
Oh, man.
- Gummi bears all on the top.
- It all got in the bottom.
Aw, that doesn't look anything
like the picture.
- That looks awesome.
- You like it? Taste it.
How does it taste?
That's, that's kind of a fail.
- Mmm. Yeah, it's good.
- Those popsicles were a giant fail
and then I realized after,
turns out that's a picture of soap.
It's not even a freakin' popsicle.
It's soap, it's a bar of soap.
That's why it's so clear,
'cause it's glycerin.
So, per usual,
it's day four?
Day four and I'm super,
super late for work.
I don't have time to make bento lunches,
but I bought a NutriBullet,
and I'm gonna make my kids a
green smoothie this morning,
so I hope that counts.
By like, the fourth day,
I really got the hang of the NutriBullet
and that was really, really helpful.
That was the one, like,
useful thing that came out of this week.
Thank goodness I found that,
because it really was coming down to like,
do I put on a shirt or
do I slice this bread?
Like, I need to decide right now.
Okay, day six, I got it together.
I made lunches.
Um, I'm super, super, super late for work
and I have a 9:30 am meeting,
so I hope I'm not late for that.
And that's all I got today, so far.
Okay, so it is the final day.
Oh my god, thank goodness.
So tonight I'm gonna make
panda-shaped macaroons.
They seem to be like,
the most complicated thing
I found on Pinterest.
Figured I'd end with a bang.
Uh, this has been quite a journey
and then I just realized,
I don't know where my
electric beaters are,
so this is going to be really fun
trying to whisk eggs by hand.
(sigh)
I beat those things with
a whisk for 45 minutes.
Ugh, I'm so tired.
(laughs)
But they worked!
I like, piped 'em out of a Ziploc bag.
I like, decorated them
out of a Ziploc bag.
I like, smacked the pan on the floor
to like, try to get out the air bubbles,
which is something I guess
you're supposed to do.
It was like, completely like, MacGyver'd.
Everything was totally, not
the way it's supposed to ...
They're actually kinda cute.
Look.
I haven't actually fed
them to my kids yet.
I just like, ate them in
the middle of the night
and that was that.
(laughs)
But it was worth it.
Treat yourself, am I right?
So in conclusion,
uh, I learned a lot this week,
and I gained a lot of
respect for Pinterest moms
and moms in general.
Uh before, when I would
see Pinterest crafts
or like think about the moms
who did that sort of stuff,
I'd just kinda do a giant eye roll,
and like, disregard it
as something stupid.
But I learned, this week,
that it really is worth it.
It's fulfilling and it's fun,
and I really wish I
could be more like that.
So definitely an overall
learning experience.
Not something I'm gonna be doing
ever again in the near future,
but it was fun for that week.
Uh, and tune in to see what I do next.
Until next time.
Does it make you wanna eat it?
- It's a batman.
- [Hannah] It's a batman cheese?
(laughs)
Sure!
- [Jackson] Oh, yeah!
Yeah, it is.
This one looks like,
this one, it looks like batman.